laurence tibérine us bonjour oui bonjour
vous êtes candidate aux élections
législatives
vous présentez dans le sud sur la liste
de la majorité présidentielle à leur
première question pourquoi vous
présentez-vous à ce scrutin
en fait je suis adhérente à la
république au marché depuis 2016 et
après je me suis proposé juste après
la présidentielle pour pouvoir parce que
pour pouvoir
appuyer le programme du maniema quoi
alors juste vous vous disiez
maniema coup puisque s'il a la majorité
il a besoin d'une majorité vous pouvoir
mettre en place le programme qui
m'intéressent puisque je suis sur le
terrain en martinique et je pense qu'il
faut aller plus vite et le temps si
c'est de la vie donc en étendant la
majorité présidentielle je pense que ça
va faire avancer plus vite
la martinique alors justement
concrètement quelles seraient vos deux
ou trois projets prioritaires pour la
martinique si vous étiez élu à
l'assemblée nationale voilà a
spécialement paul amar entier puisque si
l'assemblée nationale vous représenterez
la martinique à l'assemblée nationale et
surtout pour
axa qui concerne la réforme des
retraites parce que nous sommes
conscients des barris fonds de retraite
enfin c'est une priorité pour moi enfin
si kate dans la tronche où je travaille
les infirmières il ya un problème à ce
niveau là parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
filles mia qui ont 67 ans soixante dix
ans 80 ans qui travaille toujours parce
qu'il ya un problème
pour la réforme les retraites on
n'arrive pas à partir mais il ya des
défis mais aussi qu'ils sont
hospitalière qui prennent la retraite et
en plus qui qui continue en libéral et
qui ont des charges sociales pour ça
aussi et je pense que la réforme de
retraites elle est favorable pour nous
pas vous non seulement pour les médecins
et les professionnels de santé de façon
à régler leurs problèmes
de
manque de personnel
et que les jeunes ne parlent pas sur la
métropole parce que là c'est ce qui se
passe en ce moment et pour éviter la
situation de désert médical dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons voir alors
deuxième caisse troisième question
concernant la circonscription dans
laquelle vous vous présentez le sud est
ce qu'il y a des projets particuliers
que vous souhaitez défendre
concernant la circonscription du sud si
vous êtes élu à l'assemblée nationale
d'après vous quelles sont les
thématiques les problématiques sur
lesquelles il faudra plancher enfin il
faudrait vraiment plancher sur le
problème en fait c'est dans le programme
du bagne macron il ya déjà le défi de la
transition écologique par rapport aux
déchets par rapport
euh vous sargasses aussi oui voilà
puisque c'est déjà acté dans le
programme d'auxi on l'a tous on a tous
déjà sur un plateau donc il suffit de se
servir c'est pas puisque en fait il ya
d'ici l'automne enfin en martinique gens
n'ont qu'à les élus il propose des
choses ils ont un programme mais après
il faut qu'ils aillent demander des sous
pour pouvoir faire ce qu'il doit déjà
ils ont déjà les moyens et en plus de ça
m'a pris je me présente aussi parce
qu'en fait
je vois que les élus ils n'utilisent pas
les les utilisant d'autres disposent
voilà puisque déjà niveau de la cité
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner un
exemple par exemple exemple au niveau de
la ctm de la branche
de la pmi la protection maternelle
infantile c'est très important c'est la
base
il ya des outils mais
il ya des outils mais c'est pas
c'est pas y'a pas la protection
maternelle infantile en martinique
depuis une vingtaine d'années et c'est
terrible parce que on peut pas par
exemple par rapport à la communauté à la
protection de l'enfance hier il n'y a
pas de prévention et comme dans le
programme il ya déjà tous ces boules
s'il nationale donc nous sommes français
donc il faut y aller il faut y aller
donc pour vous en gros il ya des
dispositifs nationaux il faut juste les
connaître les batteries et les demandes
fait trente ans que je suis fier libéral
mais je suis aussi plus régulatrice donc
je connais aussi la problématique des
pour les enfants la protection
l'effeuilleuse va protéger quand les
enfants sont pas protégés ça veut dire
que les meilleurs sont en souffrance et
puis voilà c'est la base
alors est ce que vous auriez quelque
chose à rajouter puisqu'on arrive
presque au bout on est bientôt à 5
minutes qu est ce que vous pourriez vous
vous souhaiteriez dire aux électeurs est
bien de me faire confiance parce que je
suis quelqu'un qui je suis sur le
terrain depuis 30 ans par rapport à tous
les problèmes le harcèlement moi j'étais
en sa vie ma fille était à sa démo et il
ya des diables des gens qui viennent qui
viennent vers moi je suis pas je suis
pas élu mais je trouve toujours une
solution
je trouve toujours une solution c'est ce
à quoi doit faire lire d'après vous un
élu ben oui il faut tout il faut aller
vers les gens pas opter des solutions
aller sur le terrain mais ne pas rester
dans un bureau et puis
réclamer de l'argent qu'on n'utilise pas
à bon escient
laurence tibhirine us merci